La volta al món a peu, dia 287.
Són les 11 del matí d'un 12 de setembre de 2026.
Surto de la meva Guescaus, on he estat 3 dies, aquí a Murgap.
Si voleu saber el motiu de per què he estat aquí, ho explico a l'últim vídeo.
Ui, que em caic.
Avui començo l'últim tram d'aquest país, avui dissabte,
que endurà ja fins la Xina, fins a Culmapàs,
l'esperada frontera amb la Xina.
I aquest petit tram, o no tan petit, de 90 i piu quilòmetres,
el realitzaré en 3 dies.
Avui serà el dia que caminaré menys, caminaré uns 20-25 quilòmetres,
i per això surto tard.
De fet, són les 11, però encara no surto.
Ara aniré a comprar alguna cosa de provisions,
potser alguna cosa de halar, per dinar, per si ja ho tinc fet.
I també acabaré de fer alguna última gestió,
perquè probablement ja no tinc internet fins que cregui la frontera,
amb la Xina.
Què he fet aquests dies?
Vaig anar al llac aquell?
Al llac de Caracol?
Doncs no.
No vaig anar, perquè vaig anar a preguntar al taxi,
valia gairebé 200 euros,
i quan li vaig dir, bueno, podríem compartir-lo amb altra gent,
va dir, és que no trobareu a ningú per compartir-lo.
Per tant, ahir em vaig quedar també aquí,
no vaig trobar un barber,
per afaitar-me,
llavors, em vaig afaitar jo mateix,
ho he fet ara aquest matí,
amb la ganiveta que porto normal.
No ha fet mal, perquè he aplicat sabó,
llavors, mira,
el mal me l'he evitat,
però clar, amb la ganiveta em queda sí,
super super sí,
i em triga molt a créixer,
llavors em veureu bastants dies així,
amb la cara com un nadó.
Vale, he vengut a dinar,
m'he trobat uns altres viatgers,
i el David és de Valladolid.
Bona tarda, xiquets.
I el seu pare és català, m'havies dit?
Tu pare és de Barcelona.
Molt bé, i la resta, doncs, també, molt simpàtics,
i ells mengen plof,
i nosaltres hem demanat una brotxeta de pollastre,
però encara no ha arribat.
Ok, adéu.
Bye bye.
Doncs ja ho tenim, tu, les 12 i pico.
Mira un gos aquí.
Ja us dic que una de les millors coses d'aquest país
seran els animals, com faci el resum,
però bueno, això d'aquí dos dies.
Molt bé, doncs, ara sí.
Comencem a caminar en direcció de la Xina.
Let's go.
Hello.
Últims nens al qual els dic hello
i bye bye a Tajikistan.
Són molt simpàtics, els nens.
Altres ciclistes que m'he trobat aquests dies al hostel
m'han dit
que els tiraven pedres, els nens,
si no paraven. Ostres, això
a mi no ha passat ni remotament.
Alguns nens m'han demanat diners,
se'ls ha dit que no,
i ja està.
I, bueno,
alguns nens no han parat, però la majoria
saludava, tal, però mai m'han tirat pedres.
Bueno, això et trobaré a faltar,
que els nens són simpàtics.
Bueno, des d'aquí, encara des de Morgà, per la ciutat,
ja veig
l'horitzó. No veig Kulmapass
exactament, però veig
en direcció on està.
Està cap allà. Allà.
Vull dir, no està lluny. De fet, el rellotge
em marca, com veieu,
89 quilòmetres
fins a la frontera. Sí, sí, és cap allà.
Encarat.
Una altra cosa que va passar ahir
va ser això.
Fa vuit mesos, a Itàlia, va passar
això. Encantat, senyor, com et dius?
Toni, repassó.
Andreu Quinyelles.
Mallorquins. Mallorquins, eh? Ja es veu.
Ja es veu.
Es veu poca cosa. Jo, a més, faig una
missió, que és que has de
penjar això a qualque poble,
i m'ho envies al vídeo. On tu vulguis, però
la bandera de les Balears...
A veure si dura. Bueno,
algun país raro el posaré.
Bueno, que no sigui Europa, que ja no m'he aferrat moltes.
Perfecte. Moltes gràcies.
L'he estat carregant tot aquest temps, i avui
257 dies més tard
l'enganxaré aquí, a Murgab,
Tadjikistan, l'última ciutat abans
de creuar la frontera amb la Xina. Fet.
Seguiu l'Andreu, que ara farà el camí de Sant Jaume
en tenda de campanya, i el rebassó,
que ara mateix està a Uganda.
Un dia després, encara està aquí.
No sé quan durarà.
No crec que duri massa, eh?
Perquè és que aquí... Ja era bé
aquesta enganxina, ja estava una mica
gastada. Hello!
Bueno, una altra
cosa que he fet ha sigut parlar...
amb la gent de
aquesta causa aquesta. No va venir molta
gent, però va venir una parella d'americans
i anglesos
el segon dia
i el tercer, o sigui, ahir, va venir un
sud-africà que deia que està una mica
malament de l'estómac.
No m'està parlant, un tio molt interessant. Venia amb bicicleta,
anava des d'Amsterdam fins a Singapur,
i, bueno, després per la nit
no va parar d'aixecar-se per anar al lavabo
i vomitar,
i fatal. Estava fatal,
pobre. Deia que havia begut
aigua sense filtrar. Sempre la filtrava,
però un cop que
la va... Hello!
La va beure sense filtrar,
doncs li va agafar això i està fatal, va estar
vomitant, i a les 6 del matí
m'ha dit, ei tio, estic fatal.
No puc ni caminar gairebé.
Demanaràs de vegades que us comportin a l'hospital.
Aquí a Morgab hi ha un
hospital, o bueno, una espècie
d'ambulatori o el que sigui.
I no l'he vist més.
Ja no l'he vist la resta del matí. Espero que...
que es posi bé.
Has d'anar preparat mentalment pel canvi de
temperatures, perquè a la mínima
comença a bufar el vent,
se'n va el sol i
i refresca bastant. Avui, màxima
de 14 i mínima
de 3 aquí a Morgab.
Això encara no m'havia passat,
m'havia menjat molta pols de camions,
però que el vent aixequi la
torre i me l'envia
immediatament,
això primera vegada. Per sort el tinc
de darrere, el tinc darrere
el vent, perquè si ho tingués de cara,
m'hauria de caminar d'esquenes.
I ara surt el sol i ja
em torno a fregir. No porto ni 15 minuts caminant
i m'he de canviar dues vegades de roba.
I d'aquí 5 minuts tornar a anar-se'n
el sol i m'hauré de tornar
a posar.
Música
Són les dues i mitja,
porto 11,5 km.
Ara feia dies que no perdia res, no?
M'acabo d'adonar
que no porto la polsera,
la polsera aquella que m'heu vist alguna vegada,
que porto aquí al costat del reotge.
Doncs crec que me l'he deixat
estic gairebé convençut que l'he deixat al hostel,
he revisat la motxilla, no està.
Doncs torno, home,
estic a prop, torno. El que passa
és que no vull tornar caminant.
Ara veig cap allà, que allà ve un camió,
a veure si em pot portar.
Després el problema serà tornar aquí.
Desastre, tu.
Desastre total.
Música
Mare meva!
La carretera és tan dolenta
que per fer 8 km
he trigat mitja hora.
Sí, sí, literalment.
I a més a més, no m'ha deixat a Murgap.
M'ha deixat aquest lloc que reparen camions
el que sigui, i Murgap està
allà, a més de 2 km.
Per tant, he de caminar
mitja hora més
fins a la Guescaus, i ja veuràs
com no estarà. Mare meva!
Quin dia, tu, ostres.
Comencem malament, eh?
Música
no sé, suposo que els diré
10 km
i quan estigui allà els diré
stop, stop
espero no haver de caminar ara un altre cop
dues hores fins allà, no, no, no
a veure, lo bo
m'ha agafat el primer que ha passat, genial
i a sobre era un cotxe, que clar, el cotxe va molt més ràpid
que el camió perquè el camió
ha d'anar vigilant molt per on camina
lo dolent
clar, no m'han deixat
on jo volia
m'han deixat el primer poble que hi ha després de Murgap
perquè clar, és que des d'aquest poble
que hi ha aquí, que es diu Kunur Magun
fins a Xina no hi ha absolutament res, per tant
és que ningú ha d'anar cap allà
només els camioneros que vagin fins a la Xina
total
que estic a 3 km d'on ho he deixat
llavors, bueno, doncs ara
tornaré a la carretera
i potser els he de fer caminants aquests 3 km
tampoc és tant
però bueno, si posa algun
camioner
doncs li demano
doncs al final he vingut caminant
perquè no ha passat ningú
i bueno, el camió anava per allà
per aquest camí de terra, allà no l'he parat
i ara torno a la carretera
són les 14.40 i pico
he perdut
dues hores i deu
amb aquesta tonteria
a més, el sol s'ha amagat
darrere d'aquest núvol
i fa un vent fred
quin pas
de dia
a sort que només són 20 km
els que havia de fer
quin pal
bueno, mireu que maco això
el riu aquest
tot verd
en canvi, si et gires cap allà
dius, ostres, quin erm
tot sec, però aquí molt maco
bueno, són les 5.30
no faré els 20
però és que no només faré els 20
sinó que els dos primers no compten
perquè he estat donant moltes per Morgab
vull dir que
bueno, doncs demà tocarà fer més
demà tocarà fer una pallissa més gran
però encara una horeta la puc fer
insisteixo
que a pesar que el dia és un pal
el paisatge, la posta de sol
molt maco aquesta hora
bueno, com era d'esperar
17 km de Morgab i ja no tinc internet
i fins a la Xina
suposo que no en tindré, suposo
mai se sap això
i quan passa això
que estic dos o tres dies sense internet
el que passa és que quan obro
el mòbil
doncs sempre hi ha alguna notícia nova
perquè sí, a mi m'agrada
estar informat del que passa a Catalunya
a pesar d'estar fent la volta amb una peu
i bueno, però això obres
i bueno, el resultat del Barça, el resultat del Madrid
temes de política
bueno, ja sabeu, no?
Rodalies, totes aquestes coses que són un drama
bueno, m'agrada estar informat
una de les maneres que he fet és que
en les quals m'informo
és Inèdit Diari
Inèdit Diari és un projecte
de la Gina Rigol, que és una periodista
que, bueno, té la Gina Rigol
i altres periodistes joves
que amb una visió
jove, doncs
expliquen notícies, tots són periodistes, però
expliquen notícies de Catalunya
a base internacional
i tal, tenen un Instagram i allà fan
vídeos explicant l'actualitat
fins i tot el lloc dels fets
l'altre dia, ahir va ser l'11 de setembre
que jo el vaig celebrar
la diada aquí a Murgap
doncs es van desplaçar
no, va ser el dia anterior, el dia 10
als Fossades Moreles, a veure què passava, que hi havia una mica de merder
com cada any
i bueno, doncs
a mi m'agrada aquest diari perquè és un projecte independent
com jo, una de les coses de les quals
estic orgullós
a part de fer la volta amb una peu, és que
això que faig al YouTube és una cosa
que ningú
és un projecte independent, no depèn de cap
teler i de cap ràdio
no tinc ningú que em digui
el que he de dir ni com ho he de dir
tenia les beques de la Generalitat, ja ho sabem, però
a part d'això, ells mai em diuen
el que jo havia de fer o no havia de fer
doncs, Inèdit Diari és un projecte
similar, i és un projecte autogestionat
com jo, jo tinc l'aixeta
doncs ells tenen una newsletter
una newsletter setmanal que tu pots
subscriure't i, bueno, amb una
quantitat econòmica, doncs
dones suport al projecte
i et rebs la newsletter
doncs que està bé, jo la rebo, l'aixo cada setmana
també la pots llegir, crec que per substract
que jo no tinc aquesta aplicació, però
està disponible, llavors això
rebs la newsletter i estàs a la guai
del que passa a Catalunya, el que passa
al món, amb l'opinió i des d'aquesta mirada
jove, independent
i autogestionada. Us convido que aneu
al seu Instagram, aquí, Inèdit Diari
li doneu una ullada
i, si us agrada, doncs el seguiu
i, a més, us podeu donar d'alta
a la newsletter, així, doncs
els doneu suport. Us deixo la descripció
l'enllaç per subscriure-us a la
newsletter o, si no, també ho podeu fer escanejant
aquest codi QR.
A veure què hi ha, no?
Potser està oberta i puc
entrar a dins. O potser
em surt algú com...
Jo crec que aniré
a veure què hi ha.
Bueno,
encara que fos lliure, des d'allí
em semblava més gran, saps?
És molt petita.
Jo no dormiré allà
ni en un any.
No diria que fos el millor lloc del món.
Però faig la meva tenda.
Ui, hi ha una cervesa.
No, crec que no hi ha ningú.
Crec que no hi ha ningú perquè suposo que això és una espècie
de tenda de campanya
que ha posat aquí el cocacui d'algunes vaques
o alguna cosa, que ara mateix no n'hi ha cap.
Llavors es resguarda allà
per no haver de tornar a casa
o si plou o el que sigui.
Val, res, igual.
Doncs res, em posaré
aquí com a mínim.
El lloc està bé perquè és realment baixa.
Vull dir que m'alegro
d'haver vingut per aquí.
Jo vaig acampant perquè avui
són les 18 i 22
i el sol se'n va a les 18 i 18.
Això és una estafa, tu.
M'estan robant el temps.
Doncs el lloc és molt bonic.
És molt maco.
Clar, el fet d'estar al costat del riu
augmenta l'humitat
i la presència d'humitat augmenta el fred.
Llavors, avui no es preveia
una temperatura tan baixa,
potser dos graus
i amb l'aigua al costat,
doncs ja ho veurem.
Però estic preparat.
Vull dir, si vaig passar una nit a menys 5,
puc passar aquesta.
Van passant els camions i els cotxes,
però com estan lluny,
relativament,
doncs no m'ho destan gaire.
Molt xulo.
I no hi ha vent.
Aquests vents que vaig comprar, tu,
bueno, ja està bé, ja està bé.
Avui, no arribar a 20 quilòmetres,
he parat amb 5 persones,
cap refresc i dos tests.
I m'he gastat
3 euros de la brotxeta aquesta
i de la compra, res,
50 cents he comprat aigua només al final.
Bueno, aquests passats dies
m'he gastat 45 euros
amb el hostel,
perquè són 15 euros,
dos de nit i set-tres nits.
I després, entre dinars,
no sé què, no sé quantos,
i les provisions,
potser posa-li 30 euros més.
Posa-li 30 euros més, sí.
I al final, he anat bé de diners,
inclús pel just,
em queden 20, 20 i pocs euros.
Jo no sé si el lloc aquell que vaig demà a dormir,
que us he dit,
que vaig a una espècie d'aparcament de camions,
no sé si s'ha de pagar,
si tu vas allà i ja està,
no ho sé.
Espero que amb 20 i pico m'arribo.
Bueno, doncs res,
demà al final hauré de fer 46 quilòmetres,
que és més del que m'hagués agradat.
Més del que m'hagués agradat, sí.
Si volia fer 40,
bueno, doncs 46.
Els dies que vaig fer 50,
arribar als 46 ja costava.
Però bueno, tu, t'ho tinc tot el dia.
T'ho tinc tot el dia.
Vaig a cuinar un ramen fred.
El bo d'aquí, que està al costat del riu,
és que tinc aigua.
Per tant, no m'hi quedaré sense.
Vaig a cuinar el ramen,
a fer fred i després ja a dormir,
perquè tinc bastanta sol.
Bona nit.